Collide now to King we can talk to the
Ukrainian MP at Kiera ready we've been
lucky enough to have IKEA on the show
before so we're really delighted to have
you today on such a historic moment
President zelenski visiting both the UK
and France he's pretty clear isn't he
that he wants to see more support in the
form of fighter jets why is that so
important
hello Sophie thank you so much for
having me on the show well first of all
I want to extend everything that
president zielinski said on behalf of
Ukrainian people and its gratefulness
for all the support that we received
from the United Kingdom from people of
the United Kingdom and it's very
important for us that we are not only
are asking for more support but that we
are making very clear how grateful we
are and that we will never forget it
so since the beginning of the full-scale
invasion we were asking for one thing
help us protect our skies help us to
defend ourselves against the missiles
that are coming from the ear
there is no way for people in Ukraine to
protect themselves from it we're only
accounting on the air defense systems
that are not perfect so we need this
another layer of protection and it is
fighter jets they are called fighter
jets but they are actually used to
defend the sky against the missiles that
are targeting the peaceful cities the
schools the hospitals people's homes you
probably remember just two and a half
weeks ago there was a missile attack on
a building in the nepro city where 46
people died many of them in their beds
this is what we want to protect
ourselves against this is why we need
fighter jets to be able to say to to
people in Ukraine here you may not be
scared to go to bed every night
there are ways to protect you against
those attacks so we we have had so many
unique coalitions their heavy weapon
coalitions than their analog Coalition
than the high Mars Coalition and then
the Patriot Coalition which was I think
a life-changing for uh for all of us in
Ukraine then something unspeakable
happened so the tank Coalition appeared
and now we are expecting that there
would be tanks that will allow us to
free more of our territories and finally
put the end to the war with our Victory
and so what we desperately need a year
from The full-scale Envision is fighter
jet now we need the planes and uh if we
get them it will be really a game
changer in the war not on the
battlefield but in the ability of
Ukrainian people just simply live exist
you speak really powerfully about the
impact of the wall and the people who've
died in their beds as you say you know
we all remember you know images from
Ukraine whether it's bombed out
playgrounds whether it's Flats blocks of
flats just left in rubble in Ruins what
is your view of the British prime
minister's response to president
zielinski it wasn't clear to me whether
or not he was definitely signing up to
providing more Jets just saying that
there was no they had no problem with it
in principle
well first of all uh we all have heard
president zelenski's speech I think it
was hard to resist and absolutely hard
to say no uh to to what he was asking
um but also what we learned over the
past couple of months that when we hear
no from our allies it's just the
beginning of the conversation this is
why uh the fact that Ukrainian Pilots
will be training on the Jets is a huge
step forward for us because we know that
once we will have the trained pilots and
trained Marines it will be much easier
to ask for more weapons and when we get
them they they will start working uh for
us faster so
um you know Sophie will
we can't run on the hope you will right
now and today we've got another boost of
this hope
and knowing that the training start
basically means that the conversation
continues president zelenski continues
his trip to Paris and then to Brussels
and he will be giving the same message
don't only stay with Ukraine don't only
stand with us please keep supporting us
but also let's uh all see the way of how
we win the war and this is how we win
the war we need the fighter jets we need
the support we need the weapons to fight
back to defend our land to regain our
sovereignty and to end the war
I need to ask this question because I
know that there will be some people who
are watching at home who will be
wondering this
and they'll be worried about an
escalation with Russia and the
consequences of that if countries like
the UK provide long-range missiles or
fighter jets they're worried about what
it means for security in the UK what
would you say to them
what kind of escalation are we talking
about
so you see I think as of right now the
world has eliminated the nuclear threat
from Russia we have heard it from uh
China and from Indian leaders who are
saying that they are absolutely sure
that Putin would not resort to that we
want to hope that of course but we never
know but what kind of escalation are we
talking we see that Putin cannot push
back and cannot win the war with
Ukrainian Army so he would unlikely go
forward or can start another War so and
in Ukraine he already committed all the
war crimes from the war crimes list we
have suffered all kinds of of Terror and
atrocities uh on and and we know that
there are more to come because he would
not stop unless we stop him so when we
are talking about escalation I always
wonder what people mean by the
escalation I think escalation happened a
year ago and every single day since that
time we are working to
to take him down to make sure that he
would not be threatening the world
anymore and I think we have been very
successful all together in doing that
it's a very powerful answer that you
give and I remember interviewing you and
talking about you know the impact it's
had on children in particular
um and the parents of Ukraine and and
what the kind of thing that they've had
to do and to live through what is the
situation like now in Ukraine you're
talking to us from cave
so I'm running on diesel generator
because there is no electricity and as
of right now more than 50 percent of
energy infrastructure in Ukraine has
been destroyed
so we are going through this probably
hardest winter for all of us since
second world war because when you are
waking up in the morning you go and you
check if you have hit if you have
running water and if you have
electricity and if you all of your
devices are charged and it's almost
never when you have all of it and I can
tell you if we were very scared and
complaining uh that it is hard to sit in
a bomb shelter it can tell you there is
a huge difference when you're sitting in
the bomb shelter when you have heat and
you have electricity and kids can play
on their devices or you can read to them
and there's huge difference when it is
dark and cold and there is no
connectivity or no internet and it's
much harder to sustain much harder to to
still keep it up and say oh it's just a
game because it's not a game when it's
when it's when it's so scary so we have
been doing everything that is in our
powers to uh to make it easier but the
winter has been tough on everyone and I
do hope that we have like maybe a month
and months and a half left uh and and
then it will be easier on on everything
but uh but it it was indeed there and
especially in the regions that were the
occupied we are not only Energy System
has been destroyed but many things like
like almost everything has been
destroyed I have recently traveled to
Nikolai and Harrison and I have observed
that it's um
uh it's uh it's really a challenge for
for our nation to go through that and
then like to to have those uh wounds
become scars and then to heal those cars
and I still want to say how grateful we
are for all the support and humanitarian
Aid that we are receiving because for
the deoccupied regions they basically
survive on this humanitarian Aid and for
that I'm so grateful on behalf of
Ukrainian people